welcome back David Beckham's back with a
new Netflix documentary in it we learned
that Beckham was supposedly a once in a
generation footballer Posh and Becks are
described by Gary n with's straight face
as the Charles and D of sport of course
there lots of moaning about the press
the fans and his various managers so is
it all a load of old Golden Balls we
here to deci side is the man who brought
beckh into LA Galaxy Alexi Lalas and
podcaster James bar right Alexi hit me
with it then because I've always found
these two a bunch of self-promoting
wiers who basically exploit every
situation for personal financial gain
discuss yeah I mean I don't think that
the documentary is going to change uh
your opinion of them but I think it kind
of set out to humanize David and
Victoria for that matter and I think in
a sense it does I think it makes them a
little bit more likable whether you're
seeing know David putter around with his
bees and his honey or on barbecue or his
OCD when it comes to his clothes um but
I also think that there's some misses so
it's it's It's Entertainment um and I
think ultimately you get a glimpse into
what David Beckham is but only the
Glimpse that he and Victoria and David
Beckham the machine wants you to get up
right and James that's my issue with it
is that this is a very sanitizing it's a
bit like the Megan and Harry Netflix one
what all we're getting is basically a PR
job I mean I love Megan and Harry and I
think the documentary was pivotal uh
however this horrific but this
documentary is so boring I mean Rebecca
L isn't even named she's my second
cousin by incredible really yes there's
a bombshell wow yeah well she's not
named so I imagine she feels this is
quite disrespectful she's one of the
most interesting things back also David
Beckham really betrayed the lgbtq plus
Community when he worked with Qatar he
last week said that it was actually a
safe place for LGBT people even though
people are murdered for being gay there
so it does strike me as a bit shocking
that he didn't sort of bring up how part
of brand Beckham was built on he wasn't
really challenged about anything
substantive I mean it was interesting to
hear them talk and you know I mean
Beckham was a good footballer but Alexi
I've always felt that he's overrated in
the pantheon of great players he's a
good player but he was never a great
player yeah but he was you know arguably
and maybe still is one of the most
famous people on the planet and I think
that's another thing that the
documentary doesn't really delve into is
this brand I think I find it as
interesting as the actual player on the
field and to your point look with we all
know a titillating part is the affair
and the alleged cheating and all that
and if you're going to bring it up I
don't know but after watching it I
turned around and said wait that's it
because they kind of just veered off
into something else and it never
actually was addressed I get it it's
personal if you don't want to talk about
it that's fine but if you're going to
talk about it in the documentary then
there's got to be something definitive
and the intentional vagueness in that
moment I think was Stark and he missed
opportunity and one that really stands
out what what is Beckham's reputation in
America America now what' you
say now I think with the ownership that
he has with inter Miami and now bringing
Messi I think there's one of business I
think there's one of stardom I also
think that he in the history of American
soccer his coming to Major League Soccer
and to the United States I do think that
it's looked at as a seminal and
rightfully and fairly so a seminal type
of moment that changed the structure and
the league I don't think that he's
looked at in the same way that for
example P when he came and played in the
NSL looked and to your point about about
the player Messi has always been about
on the field and what he does on the
field David has been about everything on
the field and off the field and and
James Victoria Beckham and all this how
dides she come over do you oh I mean
it's so unrelatable that she had her dad
drive her to school in a Rolls-Royce and
the fact that she's trying to hide that
is hilarious listen I love Victoria
Beckham I've always loved the Spice
Girls I'm a spice boy I also think
that's what's upsetting about this
documentary like it's more about him and
I just don't really care I want to see
Victoria Beckham getting back to what
she does best and what she does best is
pointing in the spice go so can we
please get a Reunion yeah I wouldn't
mind a Spice Girls reunion uh I wouldn't
mind that actually I think it'd be quite
fun um but they couldn't have any autot
tuning they'd have to actually be heard
singing as they actually sing uh James
Alexi good debate uh thank you both I
appreciate it Ginger Spice baby Ginger
Spice as
me